[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and if you want to
support this channel and also get cool
anime merch at the same time like Keep
Calm and ultra instinct or maybe
something like your girl calls me senpai
check out our merch store link in the
description these are our own original
designs and proceeds will support more
content on the channel and now let's get
to it in this video we will be talking
about the true nature of Goku's ultra
instinct in my every Saiyan
transformation explained video I decided
to include ultra instinct as one of the
transformations because Goku's
appearance
clearly changes when he reaches this
form and also let's face it if I didn't
included a lot of people in the comments
would be asking me why I forgot to
include Ultra instinct nevertheless
because Ultra instinct does appear in
the video I received a lot of comments
from people telling me that Ultra
instinct is not a Saiyan form or
transformation but rather just a
technique that powerful warriors of
other races can also achieve this is the
dilemma that we're gonna be looking at
in this video and if you happen to be
new to the channel and you enjoyed this
type of content don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
it is true that ultra instinct is a rare
technique or mental state that is
difficult to achieve even for the gods
of destruction and this technique
enables the user to respond to attacks
automatically without thinking this of
course allows the user to use incredible
speed to effectively dodge attacks but
we eventually learned that attacks are
more difficult to master while using
ultra instincts since attacking usually
requires stock and until one learns to
attack without thinking as well their
physical attacks will be weaker as we
saw during the fight between Goku and
kefla but while ultra instinct as
described by weaves is in fact the
technique and
is also shown using it in the manga so
of course it isn't unique to Saiyans I
think that a lot of people seem to be
missing a crucial part of Goku's ultra
instinct equation while Goku uses the
technique known as ultra instinct first
during his battle with jiren and then
again during his battle with capla he
also transforms in order to use it
effectively Goku actually attains a new
form which allows him to use ultra
instinct a form which changes his
appearance his eyes change color and
become silver his aura becomes
drastically different and the first time
he transforms his voice seems to echo
just like it did when he first attained
the Super Saiyan form in the original
Japanese dub when wheeze and beerus used
the ultra instinct technique their
appearance does not change but goku
actually transforms in order to use it
so he does attain a new form this new
form is most commonly referred to as
ultra instinct omen which is how it is
named in the dragon ball z dokkan battle
game now omen means a sign or
forewarning in many cases a divine sign
of things to come
there can be bad omens like a sign that
something bad will happen or good omens
that tell us that something good is
coming our way
Goku appears to achieve this new form
when he is driven to the brink of
exhaustion and is then able to break
through his shell and unlock his inner
potential and this occurred during his
battle with jiren and with kefla we have
to remember that when goku first
achieves this new form both the grand
priest and Weez are not sure what
exactly is happening now they are both
obviously familiar with ultra instinct
and they realize that goku is now able
to use this technique but there is also
something unique about Goku's
transformation something that even the
users of
Ultra instinct the technique have never
seen before
for example wheeze is genuinely
surprised by the massive amount of heat
that Goku is generating in this state
and then in episode 115 as Goku is about
to transform during his battle with
Keppler we see him using the ultra
instinct technique to dodge Kepler's
attacks before he fully transforms into
his new form this to me confirms that
ultra instinct is a technique that Goku
is learning to master with the help of
this new form but the new form itself is
more than just the ultra instinct
technique this ultra instinct omen
transformation is a brand new form and
at this moment Goku is not only trying
to master the ultra stick technique but
he is at the same time trying to master
this new form which could have a lot
more to it than just ultra instinct I
think that this new form goes much
deeper than just ultra instinct and I
think that ultra instinct the technique
is just one aspect of this new
transformation basically what I'm trying
to say is that I think that a lot of
people are equating the technique known
as ultra instinct with this new
transformation that has so far been
called ultra instinct omen but I don't
think that you are the same thing the
technique can be used by beetles and
wiesen but when they use it they don't
go through the same type of
transformation that Goku did this
transformation is something more ultra
instinct is one part of it but there is
a lot more to it and we are only
scratching the surface of this forms
true potential so what does this all
mean well an omen is a sign of things to
come and I already speculated in a few
other videos that this ultra instinct
omen transformation may be just the base
form for a new branch of transformations
Goku share in this new form can be
compared to the Super Saiyan God form in
terms of hairstyle which in turn
is similar to the base form of a saying
except for the differences in hair color
if the super sand God formed is merely
the base form of a saying that possesses
godly key with Super Saiyan blue being
the Super Saiyan version of a Saiyan
with godly key then we can speculate
that there will also be a Super Saiyan
version of ultra instinct omen sometime
in the future after all since oh man
means a sign of things to come
it would make perfect sense for this
transformation to be just a lead-in into
a new branch of powerful transformations
I already speculated that in this new
form the super saiyan version of ultra
instinct oh man goku will most likely
have white hair and there are a few
reasons that I think this 4-1 in
Japanese culture white hair has a lot of
meaning and it symbolizes wisdom
self-control discipline purity awakening
and new beginnings another reason is
that Goku Super Saiyan God form has red
hair which looks like flames and Super
Saiyan blue has blue hair blue flames
are hotter than red flames so it makes
sense for Super Saiyan blue to be the
stronger form of Super Saiyan God
but the absolutely hottest flames
possible burn with a blue-white color
blue around the edges and white at the
core closest to the source of the flame
so hair that looks like white flames
would be the logical next step
especially since ultra instinct omen
already has a silver color theme finally
we know that the Angels all have white
hair and they are stronger than the gods
of destruction
so Goku's hair turning white would be a
good way to signal that he has surpassed
the gods of destruction and ascended to
an even higher level let me know what
you guys think do you agree with me that
the so-called ultra instinct omen
transformation goes far deeper than just
the ultra instinct technique do you
believe that as the name Allman's
suggests this form is just a sign of
things to come and go who is going to
achieve yet
another transformation sometime in the
future finally let me know what you
think this new transformation would be
called I'm thinking that Super Saiyan
ultra might be a good name but maybe it
will be something like beyond ultra
instinct or the true limit breaker Goku
since I know some people out there
believe that ultra instinct is not the
real limit breaker Goku form that we
were expecting and that this form is yet
to come let me know your thoughts on all
of this down in the comments I want to
give a huge thank you to all of you for
supporting Dragon Ball super content
here on the channel I was one of those
people that was late to the game with
Dragon Ball super as some of you may
know because as a fan of Dragon Ball Z I
was afraid that Dragon Ball super would
ruin my childhood memory but since then
I've learned to really enjoy super as a
fun over-the-top action anime that is
definitely worth watching
I am actually considering making a video
about why Dragon Ball Z fans should give
Dragon Ball super a chance so if that's
a video that you would like to see let
me know down below
we are also truly grateful to our anime
uproar patrons including Christian Fleur
Urbano T the one and only Gilgamesh and
original Inc thank you so much everybody
and also thank you to the many people
who donated to us in the past all
donations go to support more content
more frequently right here on the
channel so if you want to consider
becoming a patron the link is in the
description if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more Dragon Ball super
content right here at Anime uproar be
sure to leave a like to let me know and
if you are new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell as always thank you so
much for watching and until next time
see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]